α πολύ πιάδες που επεράσαν που άλλουχουν που άλλους αγωνιστικούς χώρους ιτο εξωτερικών γνωρίζουν επιτσε
ποτσε κάποιος κρατικός αξιωμα του χως μας όπει έλα να εύρουμε λύσεις ο κανένας ποράσουμε
ότε ποιασα εγώ νανα προσεγκίσω την κατάσταση που είνα καταλήξανα ποτέ αλλά όικανένας δε με
πήρεόταν ανακίνωσ ότι της σταμάτησαδε με πήρε κανείς τηλέφωνο ένα εκτώς από ένα άνθρωπο των
αντώνει το κειοργαλή δευθυντήτης γενικό τη ευθυντής ομοσποντί ο οποίος είνα πιπροσωπηγού δαάθως οποίασεμε που
έναν ευχαριστώ και ι εγώ ήθενα τουπο να ευχαριστώ γιατί εστηνοσί να μεκίνων είχαν παραπάνουν
επικοινώνεια με την ομοσποντία κι δε ήταν και εύκολο να διαχειριστείς να παγκόσμο που αθετί
που κανείς δεν περίμενε στην κύπρατα τόσο αχρονια από πρόσφερες ένα αντιλέφωνο δε ναιναι να
πριπροσωπικού α ξς χαριστούμε καλή συνέχεια απόδο και πέρα ευχαριστώ και λι κανέας αλλώς δεν
μ ενοχλίον το πράμα ενώήτε ότη μετέπειτα ευραβεύτικα και από την ένω σε ανθετηγο ράφων
και από τον κόα και λιπά όμως ένα καιμίσισουν το διάστημα που ελέκαμε πριν ότι
εγώ παίρνουν ένα δράμμα μουν λίγων κάποιος χαμένως τώρα να με πεήριν κάποιος για να
αναμερωτήσει τουράς το με τις δικές μου γνώσι τις εμπηρίες πως μπορούν να ποθηθήσουμε όχιι
δε με πήρε μπορεί να υπάρχουν άλλη ανθρώποι οι οποίο τα γνωρίζουν χωρίς να μαστε
νεμεσί απο λεταγνώ σας σίγουρα ήταν κάτι παραπάω τα μάθια μας και ίσω τις θα
μπορούσαμε με κάποιον τρόπο να βοηθήσουμε οιο είναι το παράπονο το ποιο συχνον παράπνον που
κουγες από τους δικούς ανθρώπους ότι εντίνος που έλειπε πι να τους αγόνες τατάξγναι κάσουν
πι τα το ποιο συχνό παράπονο πποα κοιταξει τογυναίκα μου αν και προσπαθούσει να μέμου
το δείχνι και ναμένου κανίνει παράπονο επειδή το δεκαέξει είχαμε γεννίσει στο πρώδομαςπαιδή και εγώ